(gentle music)
- There's always room for dessert.
Here's a sweet idea just for you.
- [Nadia] Okay, so I
don't make dessert often
so you wanna trust me when I say this,
Dulce de Leche Lava Cake was epic.
First, you're gonna crack
an egg and an egg yolk,
add your sugar, and you're gonna beat it
until it looks like that.
You're gonna add your
Dulce de Leche to a bowl
with your butter melted bain-Marie.
(mixer whirling)
And add it to the eggs
with your flour, cinnamon.
You're gonna grease your
ramekin with butter,
add a little sugar so it doesn't stick.
Bake them up.
Then we're gonna make
our little drizzle cream.
Run the knife through it
so it comes out smooth.
Add your ice cream, your
drizzle, and you're done.
- I'm gonna be thinking
about that day long.
(gentle upbeat music)